Okay.
Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in on you.
Okay.
No bells,
no whistles on it this week.
I'm just checking in on you so you know,
everything's going,
hoping you having a nice week.
I'm having a lovely week.
Um,
been doing a bunch of,
a bunch of,
uh,
what do you call it?
Their promotion for F is for family that comes out next Tuesday at midnight on
Netflix season
to 10 episodes of the Murphy family on Netflix.
Um,
please tune in if you enjoy it.
Please continue to watch all 10.
If you enjoy all 10,
please tell your friends and have them watch it.
So then we could do with season three.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We'll see what happens.
I um,
I don't know.
It's been such a whirlwind of press.
What the fuck did I do yesterday or two nights
ago I was at something.
I wear a sport coat.
I do know
that I have absolutely no recollection where I was two nights ago.
Last night we went over to Netflix,
this new building,
the taking over the world,
the new building and uh,
oh,
I know what I did.
I don't want,
I did.
There was for Emmy consideration,
they added,
they had the thing there and you sat there on a pen panel and it was a Judd
Apatow,
Chelsea handler.
Uh,
the woman who created friends.
I can tell you right now,
if I created friends,
I would never come out of the house again.
I'd have so much goddamn money.
I would just be sitting in there with the biggest drum kit ever.
And I'd have a fucking helicopter.
I don't know where I'd be.
It,
I'd be all fucking weird.
I'd be like growing my nail and cutting my nails,
you know,
I'd be coward.
Fucking huge.
MMM.
And it was me and then the guy from,
uh,
the Santa Clarita Diet and it was pretty cool.
You got to sit there and I'd be glad to tell us
hello.
When you're creating your show,
what is it that you do when you're creating the show?
MMM.
Okay.
This AI stuff and the show,
is it based on you?
Is it made up or is it something else that we don't know all together?
And you answered all the questions
and I hope you get out of it unscathed,
which I think I did.
Sorry.
So what's funny was I actually wore a sport coat and then Mike Price,
uh,
cocreative f a family,
the Great Mike Price from the Simpsons who I could not do f is for family
without him.
He was dressed casual.
So last night when we went to the,
the new Netflix building,
they're taking over the world.
MMM.
I,
I said I am not going to,
I'd sit in the,
I go,
you know what,
I'm just going to wear a fucking button down,
blah,
blah.
And as I pull in Mike Price as a jacket on,
I got you one fucking jacket on the bum.
So we were laughing about that and everybody else had on a jacket.
So I just look like the,
uh,
the fucking artists showing up.
Like,
hey man,
I just like roll out of bed,
man.
And Yeah.
You know,
whenever you're in feel.
And I just put it on man.
Um,
but we sat through two episodes,
the first two episodes.
It was a friendly though,
you know,
everybody pretty much in the crowd was on the show and they were laughing,
having a good time.
So I hope you guys enjoy it.
Um,
I was on rich Ising yesterday.
I don't know if he can go to some rich i's and.net and watch it.
I had a great time.
So thank you to him.
And uh,
then I did,
Bill Simmons had a great time on that one.
Um,
and I got coming up next week.
I know I'm doing Craig Ferguson,
who is the greatest special I've ever seen.
I'm doing his and uh,
there's something else.
Somebody look at my phone,
I should,
but I'm trying to promote these things.
MMM [inaudible]
before I,
uh,
doing that would probably be good.
Right.
Rather than telling you after I did them.
I mean,
that would make sense.
Bill.
The whole thing about promotions,
let people know something's coming.
Not that it came and went.
Oh,
I know.
I actually,
I have a Gig for the California Highway Patrol Booboo,
but at do
[inaudible].
Oh yeah,
I'm going to be on my best behavior.
You cannot know enough cops.
There's some great life advice.
You have no idea when you're going to snap,
you just walk into a bank,
you're going to make a deposit.
You just say,
Hey,
what if I just pulled my shirt up over my head and passed them a note?
You know,
you have no idea when for some stupid fucking reason you do that.
And then unfortunate,
hopefully when the cop shows up,
he's like,
get out of crap.
Oh wait,
is that bill?
What are you doing?
Huh?
No.
All right,
well we'll take care of this.
Everything's fine.
There was no gun already that takes you outside of what the fuck you gotta get
Outta here.
Get outta here.
His son of a bitch.
You like dead.
And that right there is called white privilege.
I don't know who's not white.
You listened to that.
You know,
we times I've gone in and robbed the bank and it's,
you know,
I've never been successful,
but I've never gone to jail for it.
It's because I am a white male,
you know,
and I might get in trouble for this.
I might lose some of my privileges if I let non.
Why do you smell that?
I've actually on six,
maybe seven if you want to get technical.
First Time it was,
I made a joke,
but on say six and a half different occasions,
I made an attempt to rob a bank I was caught but knew the cop when they will
come in in five out of six of those,
another time the guy was like,
oh,
you look just like me and you let me go.
Those are all true stories.
Um,
and you can add those to the,
to the non fake news in your life.
Um,
I flew a fucking helicopter this morning,
but getting back into it,
I'm up over 120 hours a,
my auto rotations are looking okay.
Last week they were fucking horrific.
Put the collective down,
knows,
followed it.
And I didn't go aft cyclic and it was like,
oh my God,
am I going to die
getting good on the radio again.
I got this great fucking APP.
If you want to listen.
Uh,
anybody else there is into aviation or something.
I just,
you know,
cause you don't want to sound like a fucking moron when you're making your
calls,
which uh,
you know,
I do want a regular basis.
There's an app called live a t c.
Dot net.
It's really cool.
And you just click and you can listen to whatever airport you want.
I was listening,
you know,
when my flights taken off,
I don't care about what does it,
magnetic deviation or whatever the fuck it is from my cell phone.
I wasn't magnetic something or there
retardation.
I can't,
I don't remember.
All I know is I'm going back and I'm going through all my ground school again,
trying to remember all this shit.
I'm reading about fucking weather and a,
I'm having a great time,
get myself back to where my skill level was right before my lovely daughter was
born.
And,
um,
I don't know.
I'm totally into it,
but the only thing I don't like about those Robinson's is that the mass bumping
in the low Gi pushovers and someone was telling me today that they add,
have a fully articulated rotor system.
We didn't have to fucking deal with that.
And for those of you who don't fly,
a mass bumping is basically when the blades attack the mast
and break off the ELA copter.
If they don't get bent and then slam into the cockpit and cut your fucking legs
off or you right in half,
you know,
that could happen.
So that happened on those bell helicopters I guess that they had in Vietnam.
And uh,
you can't,
you know,
when they would fly low to the ground,
they'd go up the hill.
Um,
you know,
cause they were trying to stay at the tree line so they wouldn't get shot at
they way up in the air and they would just fly and they'd go up the hill and
then when they would dive down the backside,
that's the thing.
When you push forward with the stick like that,
you're not supposed to do that in a semi articulated rotor system.
What happens to the,
see if I can remember.
Basically what happens is the main rotor is still spinning,
but it's no longer producing lift with the helicopter,
right?
They've sort of been this low g thing.
So what happens is is if it goes counterclockwise,
you main rotor,
your,
your rear tail rotor is going to be on back behind you on the left.
And so you're,
it's still going to be compensating for the torque that the main rotor is no
longer producing.
So it's going to push you over and you're going to roll over to the,
right.
Now what's fucked up is as you roll over to the right,
the way to get out of it is counterintuitive.
You would think that you would move the stick left.
You don't,
you smooth it slightly back after you go after to reload the main rotor to get
back underneath it.
So when she's fucking watching the ground coming up on the right,
like I don't want to go there.
You,
you move the stick.
Like you want to do a backward somersault rather than roll back up.
It's completely fucked up.
You've got one chance to do it.
If you pull back too fast,
I think he chopped your tail off.
So there's that,
which is why I don't fly.
If there's any sort of wind,
I don't fly.
But you know,
there's a danger with anything that you do if you're not risking,
are you really living?
Um,
I have to get on Instagram and I have to become some sort of motivational
comedian.
That's what I want to do.
I want to start giving you guys nauseated.
Fucking life lessons,
you know,
is I'm believing a gym or a fucking juice bar.
What is with all these fucking cops on the,
on Instagram acting like they're trying to inspire you.
It's,
you're not,
you're trying to show me what great shape you're it
Hashtag doing this one for you guys.
The fuck out of here.
Um,
Instagram whores,
male and female.
All right,
so the Celtics,
they want to game.
Holy Shit.
So we have game five tonight,
which every Celtic fan knows that we are basically eight quarters away.
If we can survive the next eight quarters,
we are eight now actually not eight quarters.
The next 11 quarters we are 11 quarters away from Kelly Olynyk taking over this
fucking series and getting us to the finals.
I know I say a Thomas' out.
I know they got fucking look Rod
Kevin Love.
They've got all these motherfuckers.
I understand.
Okay.
Do you know what Boston has?
We got hot so we always have never have explosive speed.
We have a strick,
no explosive newness with all our draft players.
If he's got a quick first step and can dunk where like now pass that guy on.
Where can this guy do look like he's going to trip over his own feet and he's
white.
Gimme that guy you always have.
And then we got the to like the,
the bruise and black dudes,
but we just never had those above the rim guys.
We just don't have explosive guys.
You know Isaiah is,
but you know,
he's like five foot eight.
So all I'm saying,
okay,
but you know,
Crowder,
he's going to get a say,
you know something.
The younger kids though,
Brown Bradley,
those guys,
I love how Bradley keeps trying to dunk on the brunt.
He keeps missing the fucking rim though.
That one.
I liked that guy.
So anyways,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
All I know is the remaining Celtics,
just all you gotta do is get us to the fourth quarter end game seven.
All right?
And then the garden's gonna come alive.
Galli Galli Galli and he's going to hit a fucking zone.
And I don't know what's going to happen.
He's going to be so in the zone.
He's not even gonna need a headband anymore to keep his,
his locks out of his face.
And he's just going to,
I don't know if he's going to start draining threes and that's going to be all
she wrote for the land.
Okay.
Anybody want to put money on it?
I'll put money on it right now if we can somehow survive.
The next 11 court is Kelly.
That was not a Flook.
Everybody thinks it's a fluke.
I'm telling you that man has ice water in his veins.
Arctic fucking polar bear swimming around in his fucking veins,
microscopic walks.
I'm telling you the thing is he's just bored.
He doesn't give a fuck about game five one through four or even games six or
even the first fucking half.
Actually no,
he had a good game game seven.
We just have to get to game seven and the man that I've always been confused as
to why he was on the team.
I once again got hit with a cold bucket of reality of bill.
You're just a stand up comic.
You don't know shit about sports led Danny.
Ange make the calls and if Danny Ainge says,
Kelly Olynyk is the fucking man that I am standing down.
You wait Cleveland.
I know you're fucking nervous.
You are.
You are so scared that we're somehow going to win game five in game six without
Isaiah Thomas or Kelly Olynyk gets dunked on and people go right around up.
You fucking wait man.
We get to game seven.
It's over.
That man shows up to play.
All right.
I'm an idiot.
Anyways.
Carely carely um,
let's uh,
let's move on to the,
uh,
the predators.
Holy Shit.
Hey,
anybody in Montreal,
the Montreal Canadian fans,
did you notice that the guy that you traded for,
cause he was too flashy.
You know,
you didn't like his personality.
PK Sue Bonn.
It was really your front office on this one,
but I'm going to play blame the fan base yet another form of Canadian leading a
team to the finals,
leading a team to the final level is my front door.
By the way,
if you want to what that beep was,
I didn't leave the refrigerator open.
I'm so hoping that the predators win the Cup because,
um,
the Bruins,
we'll never catch the Montreal community Canadians and the amount of Stanley
cups they have.
So all I can do is tease them about the guys that they got rid of that then went
onto win cups elsewhere.
Um,
is it petty?
Oh,
I think it's,
I think it's very petty.
Who Do you like tonight?
Games.
Seven Games.
Seven penguins.
Penguins.
Where's the fucking Ottawa senators?
Where is that game?
It was in an Ottawa.
If you're in Pittsburgh,
you want to go to the game,
you can probably just walk up to the gate and buy a ticket.
Cognos is,
it's a transient city.
You know,
it's a capital.
People don't give a shit.
They're from other places.
They're Calgary fans that live there.
Edmonton blue jackets.
They don't give a fuck.
They're not going to the Goddamn game.
Uh,
what do you guys think?
I actually,
for some fucked up reason,
I th I think,
I think auto was going to win only because,
um,
I dunno if the penguins have had a little bit of goaltender issue there.
That's the only reason.
That's what I'm guessing the 10 seconds that I've paid attention.
Why do I talk about sports right now?
I'm too fucking busy running around doing podcast.
Um,
you know what?
I was so busy last week.
I forgot to read the,
uh,
the question.
So let me read this.
Here's another person giving me shit about bills.
Fake News,
Delta Rant,
Billy fake fucking news.
I was listening to your podcast from last Monday as I was sitting on a Delta
flight heading to Los Angeles from Austin,
Texas was that partner to the fucking story and one of your readers brought up
the Delta Airlines incident where a dad was threatened to get kicked off and
jailed if he didn't stop complaining and fall in line as I was listening to your
useless fucking rent.
Still a huge fan.
I noticed how uninformed both you and your reader,
we're on the situation.
All right.
Tell him out here.
First of all,
if you guys are going to come at me with uninformed and fake news,
I,
you new to the podcast.
I don't really,
I just commented on for fucking series.
I've probably watched three minutes in.
My job is to make you laugh.
It's not to get facts.
What the fuck he think he listened into here,
sir?
I could have easily Google that and figured out what I was talking about.
Don't come at me like you some sort of road scholar like I'm impressed that
you're going from Los Angeles to Austin,
Texas.
Are you going to keep it weird when you get to Austin,
Texas?
Austin,
Texas is one of the most overrated overpopulated fucking cities in this goddamn
country.
You know why cause La concert like you keep moving there.
Who actually if he teach you research you'd realize it or not from La nor am I
from us and you.
Let me tell you somebody,
I don't give a fuck where you from.
The mere fact that you're dumb enough to try to get fucking accurate information
from this podcast and you think that I'm uninformed.
I used to do a radio show called uninformed,
which with better call Saul's star,
breakout star Joe de Rosa,
the teen idols sensation sensation from the now defunct opie and Anthony
Program.
That's what really broke up ob,
Anthony and Jimmy.
It was the sheer star power of Joe to Rosa coming in once every 16 weeks.
They just all had to go their separate ways because when they came back into the
studio,
when they looked at one another,
all they can be reminded of was was the the force of Joe to Rosa's talent.
All right,
do you want to look that one up there?
Go on one.
Your flight from La to Austin and he said as I was listening and blah,
blah,
blah blah.
Um,
okay.
I know.
Okay.
First the seat that,
that,
that the dad was bitching about being sold to another passenger was actually his
18 year old son seat.
All right,
now where did you get this?
At delta.com cause they're not as,
I don't trust these guys either.
I don't trust you either.
How do I know you're not fucking Eddie Delta,
son of a Ulysses Delta who fucking started the airline,
um,
who we put on an earlier flight by buying a separate ticket instead of notifying
delta that he was changing his son flight to an earlier flight doing this.
He thought he could magically have an open seat to him for his toddler who is
under two.
But that wasn't the case.
Jesus.
This guy's spread in the semen out,
Huh?
He's kind of an 18 year old and a toddler.
You go buddy,
keep banging away.
Uh,
you see,
when you decide to put your son,
don't fucking go.
You see like you're fucking talking down to me.
You dumb cunt.
All you did was researching my job,
sir,
is to make people laugh.
That's it.
I,
my job is not the fucking,
I don't have fucking time to figure shit out.
What am I still in school?
I got in this business to not have a job.
How am I going to sit here and researcher guys fucking emails.
I don't care what you write to me,
unless it sounds totally ridiculous.
I'm going to treat him as long.
I've also flown a lot and I've noticed that they don't give a fuck about you.
I remember one time I was on a flight and they had the intercom on,
so God damn loud,
you needed like earplugs and I said to the stores,
I go,
is there any way you can turn that down a little bit?
And she just goes,
no,
I'm sorry sir.
There's nothing we can do about it.
It's like you're telling me that they installed an intercom system without a
volume knob and it was at full blast.
That's what you're telling me.
It's there.
Why are you being difficult?
I'm not being difficult.
All right with you fucking crooked toes.
All right.
You see when you decided to put your son on an earlier flight by buying another
ticket while not telling Delta,
they assume that the,
the 18 year old son did not make it on his original flight because he didn't
check in and they weren't notified that the dad bought a completely separate
ticket.
So they gave the seat away to a standby passenger per standard protocol.
Also Faa regulation disallows a child under two to sit in a standard seat
without the proper child seat in harness.
So there's another thing that dad got wrong.
You can't have a child with a different names.
Sit in a seat that he sold to your 18 year old son.
All right,
fair enough.
Imagine all the issues this would cause.
Cause if we,
what if we allowed for anyone to use his,
any ticket that was issued in someone else's name,
his mistake was that he didn't check in and notified Delta and should have paid
the change fee to send his son on an earlier flight with the same ticket and
then buy another ticket for his toddler if he had the proper safety harness for
the toddler.
Uh,
tickets are not transferable to another passenger.
I'm not defending the flight attendant who I thought said some things that were
inappropriate by threatening jail,
et cetera.
That's really what I was commenting on,
buddy.
All right.
That they're sitting there acting like you did something in the Pentagon.
Um,
however,
the dad was completely wrong to think he can somehow put his oldest son on an
earlier flight home and then use original ticket.
What this guy,
he's got an 18 year old and a two year.
He's too busy fucking without a condom to research all of this.
How about having a little empathy for him,
sir,
on your Los Angeles to Austin flight fucking jackass.
What is the oldest sons?
Um,
which is okay.
Put his.
Okay.
However,
the dad was completely wrong to think he can somehow put his oldest son on an
earlier flight home and then use his original ticket,
which is in his oldest son's name.
How many times are you going to say the same thing on the two year old toddler?
So he and she can,
he or she can sit in that seat of Delta into the World War.
Just wanted to clear up your fake news rent.
You misinformed continental.
Good.
Everything's fake news is,
it wasn't fake news,
sir.
It was just me trying to make you fucking laugh.
Okay.
That's all it was.
I'm glad you researched and cleared all of that up.
Yeah.
At the end of the day,
at the end of the day,
I'm just here to make you laugh.
Okay,
so please people for the love of God.
All right,
and stop acting like you know I can't do what you just did.
Okay,
girl stabs boyfriend and avoid jail time because it was damaged her career.
Now what am I supposed to do here,
sir?
Am I really supposed to fucking sit here and research this as if someone's going
to go to jail with the jokes that I do or should I just take it at last so I can
get on with my fucking life?
Here's the deal.
Why don't you got,
why don't you be the fucking the fact police.
All right,
I'll do the rent the next week.
You can correct me.
That was my uninformed showed that would Joe to Rosa.
We just pick a topic.
We'd go off on it,
we'd be completely wrong,
and then we'd bring an expert in.
That was literally the shell.
People would learn things and there was laughs to be had.
All right girl stabs boyfriend and avoided jail time because it would damage
your career.
Hey there,
Billy beats.
I'm sure a million people tweeted an email you this article.
Actually,
no,
they didn't.
Well,
maybe they did.
I don't know.
This girl stabbed her boyfriend,
but the judge agreed that any sentencing would damage her future career in
medicine.
Jesus Christ.
Go Fuck yourself around.
Let me,
let me read this here.
Go to the page.
Oh,
here we go.
Click here.
Oh,
this.
This is UK news.
God knows this probably happened in America.
I find the UK people love to fucking did you see this?
That happened in your country.
You guys are all fat and stupid.
All right,
here we go.
Wow.
Jeez.
Ah,
wow.
I see what happens.
She's got this little angel smirk on her face.
Aspiring surgeon Levina Woodward admits attack,
but judge the first sentencing because of her extraordinary talent.
What?
He blew her back in his fucking chambers
and Oxford University.
Studient who's wider than my fucking legs.
Stabbed her boyfriend with a bread knife.
Okay.
It's a bread knife.
May Not go to jail because it could damage your prospects of a medical career.
Accord has heard well what sort of training and maybe she could've stabbed them
and sewed him up real quick.
Aspiring hat surgeon,
Levenia would-would 24 punched and stabbed her boyfriend during an alcohol drug
fueled row at Christ church college.
This is on the guardian.com is this credible?
She so she's on drugs and she's drunk and she punched and stabbed her boyfriend.
She admitted unlawfully wounding,
the Cambridge University student who she met on the dating app.
Tinder.
All right,
well not to blame the victim,
but what did he do?
You can do that with men.
What did he do?
Judge Ian,
they're always named Ian over there.
Ian Pringle.
Nigel or Ian QC.
I'm sitting at Oxford Crown Court.
Oh,
this is like the school court.
Is that what it is?
That she'd go to trial at the fucking school that's taking her money?
I don't know.
Said he would take an exceptional course and defer sentence for four months
hinting that Woodward would not be jailed because of her talent.
It seems to me that this was a one off.
This was a one off drunk,
drugged up stabbing.
Is that what goes on in England?
If you go to Oxford,
they give you one free pass.
As long as it's a bread knife and not a steak knife.
A complete one off to prevent this extraordinary,
extraordinary able young talent,
young lady lady from not following her long held desire to enter the profession
she wishes to would be a sentence.
Uh,
would be,
uh,
which would be a sentence which would be too severe.
There's some fucking judge speak to enter the profession she wishes to would be
a sentence which would be too severe.
He said,
that's sounding fake.
That sounds like somebody's trying to sound like a judge.
What you did.
We'll never,
I know leave you,
but it was pretty awful.
Pretty awful.
That's an understatement.
And normally it would attract a custodial sentence.
She's going to be a janitor,
whether it's immediate or suspended.
He said Woodward who lives in Milan,
Italy with the mother stabbed her then boyfriend and the leg after punching him
in the face,
it was below the waist.
So that's a misdemeanor,
right?
She then hurled a laptop glass and jam jarred him during the attack on the 30th
of September last year,
the quarter she was in court to hear the judge's comments.
The court was told that Christ's church would allow her to return in October
because she is that bright and has had articles published in medical journals.
Do.
Do you realize that if this is true,
how fucked up this is
that then they have the,
the trap car that they drive down to impoverished areas and they leave it on
with the keys in it and the door open.
Why don't you fucking help somebody out down there?
You gotta be white as a ghost going to fucking Oxford and they know they're
going to make a bunch of money off your given a prescription drug someday.
Wow.
All right.
Anyways,
Woodward will be sentenced on the
25th of September.
She was given a restraining order and told to stay drug free and not to Raya
friend.
Hey,
if you don't mind,
could you stay away from the person you stabbed and lay off the fucking pills or
whatever the hell he said she had taken a spoken for.
Christchurch said,
I'm afraid that Christ's church does not comment on the circumstances of
individual students.
I'm a little confused if that was a,
uh,
I would think that that would make it to real court.
Not just,
okay,
she's a little thing to fucking Luna ticket,
but she's an animal in the rack.
Huh.
Um,
yeah,
I mean that's par for the course.
I mean,
women do not pay the same fucking price.
You know,
white guys get away with shit that black guys did.
It's all fucking,
there's all different.
Before you do the crime,
you really should just do the math and be like,
what am I?
Oh,
what's up sweetheart?
She's coming in here and he,
I can't,
I can't be funny without cursing.
You can't bring my lovely daughter,
my daughter in there,
Mike.
Um,
am I watching here now?
Is that what's going on?
No,
I coming out.
Oh,
you're coming to hang out.
you want to be on the podcast?
Me?
Hey,
listen to this shit.
Some woman punched,
stabbed in through a laptop through a window and a drug and alcohol fueled rage.
And they gave her a suspended sentence because of her extraordinary talent in
the medical,
or pretend it could damage your career in the future.
She's stabbed the laptop.
No,
she stabbed her boyfriend and the leg.
Oh,
get over here with a bread knife.
It was a bread knife.
You know what the fuck?
You can't go around stabbing people even as a bread knife.
Nia Renee Hill.
You know you want to make a bumper sticker.
You know what?
That's good.
You can't go around stabbing people.
That's right.
You can't go around stabbing people even if it's with a butter knife.
So what is it?
They let her off?
Why?
I'll show you what it is.
That's what it is near because she is white.
Yeah.
It goes to Oxford.
Okay.
We could damage your career.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
Whether a little other little,
uh,
little blondie white girl and a moto jacket.
Mm hmm.
That says in is sitting in this world.
Yeah,
exactly.
Okay.
And when she actually killed somebody,
next time we'll see you can't kill some of the butter knife show use.
I show you this fucking steak knife next.
She's crazy.
Is a butter knife for gateway to a steak knife?
I believe so.
I believe if you're willing to pick up a butter knife,
you're willing to pick up just about anything.
You conclude your case.
Yeah.
Can I,
can I hear your closing arguments for this white lady?
If you were talking to the jury.
All right,
you were in England.
See wearing a powdered wig so it's even more creepily white for you.
Go ahead.
I have,
I have to wear the part I think everybody has to wear when over there they're
begging to dress up over there.
I'm a king.
I'm a queen.
Who won the Dutches.
Okay,
Ladies and gentlemen of the jury,
I know that.
What's her name?
Uh,
Levenia.
I know Luvenia Luvenia Woodward looks innocent,
but you're staring into the eyes of a psychopathic would be,
that's all I got,
man.
I thought you were going to trash her mice wispy way.
Few little white bitch.
Yeah,
he break.
If I tried to hand her a nail file from an airline mechanic to complete with,
uh,
to compete with cheapo airlines like southwest or jet blue,
the majors need to oversell seats.
In the case of passenger misses their flight.
When passengers Miss Flights,
they essentially buy two seats for one,
the one they missed and the one the airline rebook them on.
They do this to maximize revenue per flight.
I'm against what United did because they could have paid someone 1 million for
this seat and still not lost as much as they did.
Unfortunately,
entitled people want to pay for an Uber and sit first class.
Uh,
it's hard to balance enough profit to operate in eight three 21 cross country
keep prices low and still try to run the airline like it did in the 70s.
Flying isn't as prestigious as it used to be and everyone is looking for a way
to save a buck.
Love the show.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
so evidently passengers are also,
um,
to blame.
Well,
let me ask,
well,
what was going on in the 70s that isn't going on now?
Is there a way more people flying?
Did you guys go after bottom feeders?
So you have more airplanes so you have more overhead?
I don't understand why it was so proceeds prestigious back in the Ron Burgundy
days and they treated your way better and now they just jam everybody,
you know,
in the back of the plane and try to put the seats close together so they can get
more.
Rose.
Did you say Ron?
Burgundy.
Yeah.
That's not a real person.
No,
but that the era was like in the 70s.
Okay.
The Ron Burgundy Seventies.
What's the matter with that?
That's the matter with that man.
Um,
I would say,
uh,
I want it.
Why is that?
I,
this is really interesting to hear from people who actually work in the field.
Like what happened?
Um,
what happened to the price of fueled go up so high.
I don't get it.
Why won't they just raise ticket prices?
Because on the average person couldn't afford it.
Well,
good.
Then get on the f out of there,
right?
Like,
well,
sorry,
I,
I don't know why I came in here.
I'm really kind of checked out.
All right.
Yeah.
Well you've got,
we've got,
you've been dealing with the kid all day.
Hoof puked on me.
Right before I did this,
she didn't puke.
It was spin up and it was just a little bit,
you act like you're witnessing someone getting executed in front of you.
Every time she spits up,
you're like,
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Like,
oh that humanity.
I was sitting there and she was smiling and out of nowhere she went and just
fucking all came out and it's all warm.
It's like somebody poured clam chowder on me and I was laying down.
So one on my shirt,
my belt,
my pants,
and it's just like,
yeah,
I have to guide the normal reaction to somebody puking on you,
no matter how cute they are.
How cute you all right.
Let me,
let me wait.
Wait,
what did you do?
What'd you do?
Christ.
What did you
all right.
I hope that wasn't a bunch of silence here.
Maybe it was,
maybe it wasn't.
I don't know.
Um,
I see someone wrote you something about an article that I read.
Oh,
my family's slaves article.
Yeah.
That was an intense article.
I want to,
what does this person say?
Can you read the question?
Yeah,
that's what I was going to do.
Can you not sit on the recorder again?
All right.
My family slaves article.
Hey,
Bilbo Baggins,
longtime listener.
First Time emailer.
Um,
I read an article written by Alex [inaudible].
He's dead now.
Okay.
That shocked me,
but didn't really necessarily surprise me and I love your cultural,
your cultural perspective on it.
Oh my God,
this is so fucking long.
And this article,
this guy talks about his family owned a slave for 50 years.
Even after immigrating to America,
they smuggled her with them and all that.
They treated her like shit and never paying her,
forcing her to sleep on top of laundry.
I imagine it's the dirty laundry.
Why would you want to have somebody in constantly beating her for the tiniest of
errors?
Only when the writer grew up with an American identity that he realized what
they were doing to the poor woman wasn't right.
Did he and his sibling confront their parents over this,
hey mom,
you know you've been paying this ladies sleeps on our clothes.
Gordy,
my teacher,
that's not right.
As a guy of Chinese descent raised in the Americas race in America,
I've witnessed poor people like this firsthand.
Growing up,
visiting family back in Hong Kong,
I'd see my cousin,
they're millennials by the way,
being tended to by a young Filipino girl,
no older than her twenties I never thought much of this back then.
Looking back,
it seems pretty fucked up.
I asked my mother about these kinds of people and she simply said,
that's just the way things are.
These girls are poor.
They need to support their family and that's the only kind of shitty employment
that they can get.
Once my grandfather took me past city hall in Hong Kong on a Sunday and I saw
hundreds of young Filipino girls just sitting on the ground doing absolutely
nothing.
I asked him,
what was that all about?
He said that Sunday was the day off and they had nothing better to do than
loiter.
They sent all their money back home to their families,
so it's not like they could shop or go to a restaurant or anything.
They ate and slept with their employers.
I never seen my grandfather turned his nose up at a group of people like that
ever before.
My grandfather whose parents were murdered by the Japanese during World War II.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I've read about that shit.
The rape and Nan King,
every that shit,
they fucking Japanese went off and had to walk to the orphanage after finding
out Jesus Christ.
I've had an easy life.
One of the kindest,
most empathetic old farts I know.
Loved randomly hugging white people.
He called them hellos because that's what they'd say to him.
One of these people out.
Uh,
here's the article.
I'm just curious what someone like you raised with purely Western centric
ideologies would say about something like this at,
well,
I mean,
this country was kind of built on that.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I think it was built on flavor.
Yeah.
I can't really step away to,
well,
we don't do it anymore.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
obviously I think it's,
it's all right.
I mean,
not now,
but you should read the article.
It's,
it's pretty powerful,
that whole thing because this woman was given to his mother by her father and
they're Filipino and that's just,
yeah,
they were just like,
here,
this person is going to take care of you.
So she kept this woman throughout her life and it became her children's care
keeper.
Yeah.
Cause she didn't want to do any fucking work.
And then she moved to America and be like,
Oh my God,
I've got to take these kids out for a Sunday.
No,
no.
That's again,
that's just like the culture,
like this person is your nanny and now like you inherit them or something like
that.
So it wasn't even as if she had,
it's this part of their tradition.
I have to be not like all of that.
This guy grew up and then he realized that this woman wasn't getting paid and
all this other stuff and he didn't realize it until it dawned on him.
Like she is a sleigh.
And so he tried to make things better for her in her later life after his
parents died and all this kind of stuff.
But backrub yeah,
no,
but by that time she,
you know,
didn't know any other life,
so she didn't really,
she wasn't like,
yeah,
I've been waiting to go shopping at the mall like this whole time.
Right.
This is so fucking sad.
That's like when it gets very,
like Dubai,
Dubai,
they tell all those people in east of there that,
hey man,
c'mon here and help us build all these beautiful buildings.
You make all this money,
you'll get out of poverty.
Then they get them there and then they'd take confiscate their passports and
that's just slave labor that builds those fucking places.
And then they,
uh,
like the number one,
the only way to get out of it is they like commit suicide.
Right.
It's fucking brutal.
Then you watch your shows in the big balloon,
tinted whores go over there to buy a fucking bag.
Not a fan.
Not a fan of Dubai.
Why can't they be sinless like the United States of America?
Uh,
no.
That's all horribly depressing.
And,
uh,
I don't know what to tell you about that as far as like,
I don't know how you do that to somebody.
There you go in there,
goes to comedy right out the window.
Um,
I wonder why he,
I'm just curious of why this person asks.
Like,
I'm curious what someone like you raised with a purely Western centric
ideologies would say about something like this.
Again,
it's like,
are you forgetting that this is America?
Those built,
yeah,
but I didn't grow up with that.
So what he wants to do is get an outside perspective.
It's actually an intelligent thing that you've been like,
Hey,
I'm not from here.
I grew up here,
but you know,
I also have connections,
you know,
back there.
So what do you think about this?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
You know what I think,
uh,
I think it's a terrible,
I'm going to go on and say that.
That's fucking terrible.
I have so much more shit to Renia.
You have to get out of here cause you're just gonna.
You're gonna prolong it.
Oh,
I thought you were only doing half an hour.
All right.
Hold on over here.
Sorry.
All right.
Real quick.
Let's let me,
let me read this.
Cool cars.
Hey,
Billy Bruin balls.
I'm a huge fan all you are 18 and under.
Excited that you've become an f one in Moto GP Fan.
I follow both of your,
these incredible sports since the mid eighties.
If you haven't already seen the documentary,
uh,
center or
Siena Johns Santa isn't.
I saw that.
I actually did watch,
I don't know to pronounce his name.
Don't you should.
It does a fantastic job of explaining the myth around the great formula one
driver and his intense rivalry with Mclaren teammate Alan Prost.
Uh,
I know you're always looking for cool website.
Here's a link to a really cool auto auction website and it's a bring a
trailer.com.
I'll check that out.
All right,
here we go.
Here's some fucking advertisement before we play a little music and then play a
greatest hits thing.
All right.
Five,
four mentioned the importance of feeling good in your clothes.
All my God,
when I walk around in jeans,
I want my fucking legs to feel great.
Looking good.
Doesn't need to cost a fortune five four club is revolutionizing the way men
shop,
not the ladies.
The way the men do it at five four club,
they found a way to make men under five foot four looks stylish to tall women.
No.
At five four club,
they found a way to make great looking clothes affordable for everyone else.
Oh Jesus.
This is person servant going to make them sleeping on top of the clothes before
they sewn together.
Five four club.
Also understand that your time is extremely valuable.
Why wasted at the mall or wandering around in the stores?
Dude,
I swear to God,
strip malls and malls.
Do you think in the future,
in near,
do you think they're going to exist anymore?
If more and more companies like this,
there's going to be no post office.
You won't go to the fucking mall.
Everything's going to be a luxury high rise,
right?
With indentured servants milling around out front during the Sunday,
I dunno,
each month they send you a curated box of two to three items that are handpicked
to match the current season in your style.
Five,
four club partners with cutting edge designers and brands,
so you'll get the same quality as top designer clothes for way less.
They've been helping men with fashion for over 15 years and shipped over 100,000
men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg use five four club in five.
Four is featured in Gq,
vice and instyle among other publications.
Nia,
a little look over there.
He didn't believe them.
Absolutely.
Well,
I'm on the way that my Oscars,
you know,
someday I'm going to call the five four club.
They know what they're doing,
so if you don't,
that's okay.
Five four club will help you build your wardrobe one month at a time.
Oh,
Bato Popo,
me on these.
Me.
Everyone needs a slave Badu due to on me undies work until they in the grave.
Your balls field nice and soft because they polished in with the underwear they
made and that's fucking evil.
Bottom white.
It's part of my id and a,
I'm really sorry.
All right,
me on.
Hey Bill,
what do you think about lifelong slavery and somebody's dreams being crushed and
so crushed that they don't even have any dreams and they don't want to do on a
Sunday?
I love to hear your Massachusetts Western take on that discuss.
All right,
pride starts on the inside,
so celebrate yourself with me on these [inaudible] makes the ultimate feel good
undies with free shipping right to your door.
Satisfaction guaranteed designed in La.
Every pair of me undies is made with micro modal model of fabric.
Three times softer than cotton.
There's soft,
stretchy undies come in and ever changing array of colors and patterns.
No matter what your style,
they've got something for you.
That's because me undies believes in people feeling good and it all starts
around your balls and being themselves,
which is why me undies is putting their money where their mouth is,
where their underwear is,
and where your balls dangled during pride month for every special pair addition.
What for every pair of special edition,
celebrate undies.
What?
Celebrate undies year you buy during private poor fucking bastards every month.
They've got to figure out a way to make these things exciting.
Uh,
me undies will donate $1 to the Los Angeles LGBT center.
What is that long,
Long Gary Bateman technologies.
Lesbian,
gay,
bisexual and
transit.
Continental sexuals people who are trans who transfer.
What do they say that Trans Trans Lau transition on a flight across the country.
What does their underwear look like now?
Wait a minute.
Do they have special underwear?
Huh?
Nasty pig underwear?
No.
You know what it is?
It's like if you have a dick and then eventually you're not going to have a
dick.
They offer the New Slowly Closing Front pee hole right under.
Where can they do that?
Slowly closes up.
They call it the Bruce Jenner.
Um,
and if
the gold metal underwear to Cath Alon underwear,
um,
as,
as if you need another reason
shakes.
She liked it.
And if you need another reason to try me undies,
they're offering 20% off your first pair and a satisfaction guarantee that
you'll love them or your money back.
Just visit our URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash head to me on these.com and pick up a special pair
addition.
Celebrate undies.
I just can't get to that sentence.
A special edition.
Celebrate undies.
Celebrate is like cat.
I mean it's,
it's missing a word.
Celebrate on knees.
There's no comma,
so don't go up like you know what's going on.
You'll not only get a discount on some awesome Monday,
she'll be donating to an amazing cause.
Check out [inaudible] dot com slash bird today.
You know what I realized when they remove a dick,
somebody has to take that,
put it in a bag and like walk down a hall with it and put it in like a hazmat
thing.
Like where does that go?
Where are you all the days?
Where do you where?
Where do all the cutoff?
The X go.
Long time passing.
You know that song?
Yeah.
Where do all the [inaudible]?
That was a Kingston trio long,
long time ago.
Where did bruise his penis go?
I imagine iconic penis that should've gone to the Smithsonian Institute.
That thing was flopping left and right as he fucking threw javelins.
And all that stuff.
Simply safe.
Everybody did.
You just have a body part removed and you want to put it somewhere safe.
Get is simply say,
I'm protecting your home and family is easy with [inaudible].
Please save home security.
Simply safe enters sensors,
motion sensors in glass break sensors.
Make your home a burglar's worst nightmare or biggest challenge.
If you're going to keep talking shit.
Um,
can you install?
You can install the system in under an hour.
Simply say's comes preprogrammed to work out of the box,
just plugging the base station and it'll talk you through the whole process.
Seriously.
Even someone who isn't the slightest bit handy can install it.
That really means if you're a dumb fuck like me,
you can do it.
The entire system is wireless,
so there's no need to drill holes in your walls or do any other permanent
damage.
And once you're all set up,
simply safe makes it is just as easy to stay protected month to month with
simply safe.
There is no longterm contracts,
no hidden fees.
It's just 1499 a month for 24,
seven professional monitoring in emergency dispatch service.
That's three times less than what the other guys charge.
God is simply safe.
bird.com s.
I.
M P,
There's no why.
Simply supply safe.com and get 10% off your home security system.
That's simple.
Fly safe.com for 10% off.
Hey,
sit.
Play safe.com s.
I.
M p L.
I,
Sierra,
India,
Mike,
Papa,
Lima,
India,
um,
legal zoom.com Jesus Christ.
One more
in order to successfully run your business.
Attention to detail is so critical.
One contract,
one contract slip and you are fucked.
Now once contracts slip up or legal misunderstanding can really set you back.
Fortunately there's legal zoom.
You may already know that over a million Americans have used legal zone to start
your business.
Start businesses,
but legal zoom service go well beyond business formation.
I'm sorry honey.
I know it's hard to listen to me read out loud.
They built a nationwide network of independent attorneys who can provide legal
answers to the day to day questions you have about your business.
Because let's face it,
things like trademarks,
employment laws and lease agreements can get pretty complicated.
So don't waste your time,
your valuable time,
trying to wrap your head around all of the fine print.
Use Legal Zoom for that so you can focus on growing your business.
Instead,
you'll get the legal help you need without being billed by the hour.
Since legal zoom isn't a law firm,
go to legalzoom.com today and be sure to enter the code Berbee you are in the
referral box for special savings only@legalzoom.com.
All right,
that is the podcast for this month.
And um,
I get now for this,
for this stars day.
I'm all over the map here.
Uh,
thank you for everybody writing in and I like everybody writing in from
aviation,
defending the,
uh,
the aviation land,
defending,
um,
your side of it.
That's good,
fair and balanced.
Uninformed Shit is what I,
that's what I'm all about.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast.
Have a great weekend.
Uh,
I can't say the c word.
I've said [inaudible] every other damn word here in front of my daughter.
My daughter.
Is that my dog in there?
Um,
hey,
I can't say,
hey sweetie,
give me a smile.
Okay,
air.
It is.
Do you know only Nia can make her laugh?
Um,
bombing with my own daughter.
It's devastating.
This is what I do for a living.
Um,
all right.
Enjoy the song and enjoy a greatest hits from a podcast gone and a Thursday from
a long time ago.
I'll see you on Monday.
Let's read some of the,
uh,
the questions here for this week.
Oh,
we got an update.
I love when there's an update.
I remember last week,
the,
uh,
the granny fucking war.
Remember that story?
All right.
Here we got an update.
Hey,
they're all Billy fucking water.
I got an update for you on this one.
Uh,
the story has good news and bad news.
All right,
so last,
last week,
for those of you who didn't listen,
I'll give you a little recap.
There was some kid,
uh,
you know,
he was,
he's basically,
he's engaged.
He's getting married in six weeks,
so he's over his fiance's house as his future in laws house,
her fucking parents.
That's all I'm trying to say.
Right.
So they're playing some card game and evidently they're down to the final hand
and he has,
uh,
the cards called granny water.
I don't know what the game is or whatever.
Some people send me pictures of the car at the game does exist,
but it's a really high point card or whatever.
And he was laying down,
ah,
fuck,
I'm Yon.
And sorry was laying down his card last.
I basically,
when he laid it down,
he was going to do the old fucking right there.
Fred.
I won the game and uh,
he had the granny water card and I guess in the end of the game is probably,
you get it,
you hold onto it and you played at a crucial point.
So everybody's sitting there as everybody's laying the cards down,
waiting to see who's going to fucking lay it down.
So this kid fucking his finally his turn,
he lays it down to be like,
you know,
like hitting the last second three.
I just won.
And because he listens to the podcast and set of saying,
I got the granny water card.
He goes,
he goes,
look,
it's all fucking grant now.
He goes,
it's granny fucking war.
And just screamed it
to his in laws.
Okay,
who never heard this guy curse before and do not listen to this podcast.
So they just stared at him like,
what?
What was that?
What is my daughter marrying?
Like he just completely screwed the whole fucking thing up.
So he's asking me for advice.
Should he bring it up?
Shitting up,
bring it up.
All right,
now you guys are caught up.
Here you go.
He says the story has good news and bad news.
The good news is my fiance's parents were super cool about the whole thing.
Um,
I bit the bullet and waited until we went over for game night again last night.
I apologized of course,
and they said,
they initially just thought,
why are y'all really like this?
Fuck?
They initially thought it was really odd for me to yell like that without
knowing,
without them knowing the context.
The,
once it was explained,
my fiance texted them about it.
It was no big deal.
It was a huge relief.
We played the game again and every time someone played that card,
they did the whole granny water thing minus the fucking in the middle.
Okay,
cool.
He goes to,
my embarrassment will be immortalized.
Uh,
the bad news is that I mentioned that you read the letter on the podcast.
Oh No.
Okay.
You know what?
You're one of those guys.
Do you just like you just like stepping in shit.
He goes naturally.
They wanted to listen to it.
I thought it wasn't a big deal because they lived through the story and your
commentary was hilarious.
I warn them about the explicit nature of your podcasts and that there were
plenty of fucks throughout.
The fact that he did the grantee water thing before it was even brought up,
uh,
was perfect.
Everyone thought the story was hilarious.
That is until the p s
uh,
if you recall,
I may or may have not called Hillary Clinton a comment.
Uh,
Jesus.
That's right.
You did.
He goes,
yeah,
I know.
I'm a dumb ass bill.
My fiance just turned to me and said,
did you write that?
Uh,
he said,
my fiance turned to me and said,
did you write that with that look on her face?
I knew I was fucked,
so I did the only thing I could,
I said,
oh,
sorry about that.
I didn't write it.
Bill's email screener guy did.
Andrew did.
He picks the emails each week.
Then writes the little opening line,
pun and then sometimes throws in a ps to make them more entertaining.
When or why would you write this?
Cause if they listen to this,
you're fucked.
Do you know what dude,
I have no sympathy for us.
Here we go.
He goes,
they bought it.
So he just listened to the rest and we're laughing again by the end.
So I through Andrew onto the bus on that one.
I'm going to repeat my only good move from the last story and just shut the fuck
up about it forever in the end.
All is well.
Thanks for reading it on the podcast.
It seemed to help smooth it over.
No worries.
Just tell him not to listen to this one.
He goes,
by the way,
um,
I just bought tickets to your show and I'm not going to say where the show is in
case anybody's figuring out who the fuck this is.
It's the week after my wedding and my fiance slash wife by that point is coming
too.
I'd love to meet you in person.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Uh,
all right.
Well yeah,
I'll be hanging out after Iowa.
Just scream out.
Oh,
I just said where it was.
well you're fucked.
Granny water screaming out and fucking say Allodia.
All right,
now everybody's going to do that there.
Hey,
what's up?
This is bill bar for some reason,
uh,
the podcasts that I did on Memorial Day,
I dunno,
it hasn't been able to upload.
So now what I've done is I've turned it into two parts because I think it's
been,
I think it was too long.
So here is part one of the 54 minute Memorial Day,
Monday morning podcast at the end of this one.
You'll listen to part two,
Huh?
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
May 25th,
2009 Happy Memorial Day to one and all.
Ah,
you like liked that.
Is that one of the most happiest Kris kringle ways I've ever started a fucking
podcast.
Yeah.
Happy Memorial Day at thank you to all the,
uh,
all the troops out there who are serving,
who have ever served.
Add A,
yeah.
Get yourself a burger today or whatever the fuck you supposed to do on this
holiday.
What are you supposed to do?
Are we supposed to go to a parade?
Isn't that what you're supposed to do?
You know,
I'm not going to a parade.
I uh,
I'm not big on parades.
I don't like them.
I find them boring once I've seen the first band,
I get it.
All right.
You're all basically playing the same song.
It all sounds like the same song.
And I hate when a big fucking college band starts playing top 40 hits.
Like it's going to sound good.
You know,
like,
oh,
that's the way Beyonce should have done that song.
She should've had 58 guys on a Tuba and 26 guys on trumpets.
I'll play in that fucking,
uh,
if you like it there,
you Barry Blair to vague on it with the fucking trauma,
you know,
28 fucking guys doing that shit and then you're all fucking walking with the
same feet.
Hey,
we're all taking a left at the same time.
Ah,
go fuck yourselves.
You know,
I just liked the drum line.
That's all I like.
Other than that,
you know,
parade music sucks.
There's a couple of them.
Bam,
ba Ba bum ba Ba ba bump ba bump
bet.
Eh,
it,
they're happy
fit bit,
but that's great.
Watch everybody prance around and their red jackets with the gold buttons.
That's fine.
I'm all over that,
but that's it.
Once it's done.
All right,
let's drink now let's fucking fire up the grill.
I don't need to see another one of those.
Where?
Pap Pap pap pap
pap pap pap pap pap about Jesus Christ.
How many more
coming on Derek's ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome the girls choir with their little twiddle sticks.
Whatever the fuck you Bhutan's.
Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Ooh,
ha ha.
You know,
just standing there.
My big forehead just burdened in the fucking Sun.
In what?
In what comes in the end.
It's either Santa Claus or a fire engine.
That's the end of the fucking party.
Oh,
those firemen sitting on the truck fresh after banging a hooker,
you know,
are stealing the cash out to somebody buttoned down in a closet when there was a
fire in the basement.
You know,
I love talking shit about firemen now cause I don't respect him.
I just love how they just have this fucking Dudley do,
right?
People love firemen.
They hate cops.
They love firemen.
You know your house is on fire.
They show up,
right?
Your cat gets stuck in a tree who comes running down the street and a raincoat
with a fucking ladder.
The goddamn firemen,
they get a call,
you know,
did not like cops polishing off a donut.
They stay fucking slide down that stripper pole and they get it on the big red
for who the fuck doesn't like a fire engine.
You know,
I saw a fire engine fucking yesterday.
I was coming under the dog park with my dog and there was like three of them
lined up and I guess they were doing some CPR core.
I don't know what the fuck they would do when they had one of the firemen,
you know he was,
he was strapped down to a Gurney.
This isn't some gay shit.
They were like fun.
They will,
they will,
they will learn it.
Some sort of procedure,
probably how to move someone who has got a spinal cord injury or whatever,
but they all the fire engines lined up and I got to admit there's something,
there's a little kid and everybody you get near a fire engine is fucking great.
Big Red fire engine with all that fucking chrome,
you know?
I mean,
who as a kid didn't want to be that guy at the back of the fire engine driving
the thing down the fucking street.
You know what I mean?
That's what I'm going to do someday when I get super famous.
That's the perk that I'm calling in is I'm going to be,
I want to fucking drive that thing down the street.
You know,
they take you on a straight away.
You realize how much those fucking trucks cost.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't either.
I have no fucking idea how much they cost.
They got to cost a lot.
Right?
You know,
dude,
you got to figure a fucking Winnebago.
If you get a nice one,
cost you 150 grand.
Now what have you had a Winnebago that could actually put out fires,
you know,
or save someone with a spinal cord injury?
You know what I'm saying?
Like that,
that would be,
uh,
that'd be at least 200 grand.
Right?
You know,
I wonder if I can fucking Google that right now.
You don't realize today if you click on f four,
you get an a on your computer.
Uh,
at least on the Mac book,
you get the calculator,
you get the weather for the week,
you get a calendar and you get a clock.
You know,
I know that's basic computer shit.
That's not what I do here on the podcast.
You know what?
I'm not googling that shit out.
It's got to be a fireman.
A two who fucking,
uh,
listen to this podcast,
right.
And I'm on trash and cops,
by the way,
either I'm not,
I'm just saying no,
everybody doesn't like cops.
Cause when cops show up,
you know,
he the just got beat down by your husband or you're getting a fucking speeding
ticket.
You know,
that's when cops show up.
firemen show up like a,
you know,
they,
they stick a ladder.
It's like very romantic.
They put a ladder up to your bedroom and they just take you away from it all.
You know what,
maybe I'll start that.
Let's,
let's start a,
a new segment on this podcast where you actually,
you gotta tell a bad story about a group of people that only gets good press,
like either fireman.
What about the troops?
You know,
straight at Greeno on Memorial Day,
straight across the board,
support the troops.
Do you support the troops,
support the troops?
You know,
because I'm such a Cunt,
I've actually broken down supporting the troops.
You know,
too.
I actually have so much free time that I actually sat there and I was like,
really?
I just have to straight across the board,
support the troops.
Every single one of them.
You know,
every single one,
like there's not one asshole in the navy that even his fellow fucking people in
the navy can't fucking stand.
You know,
there's some current right now on a fucking aircraft carrier who's just not
pulling his weight.
He's always fucking off any.
Nobody knows exactly when to fucking pop to attention.
When,
when some,
when some officer comes by,
you know there's not one douche bag in the navy that is other navy buddies
aren't thinking of just pushing overboard.
Give me a fucking break.
Okay,
so that I support the troops but not the Douche bags.
How about that?
I'm actually gonna make that into a bumper sticker and I'll just have a
camouflage background so no one will question it.
Well wait a little Millard,
break it down here.
Where are you guys saying he supports the truth?
We're not the Douche bags.
All guys are douchebags must believe the people who don't support the troops.
Now Dude,
the Douche bags are the guys who are troops but happen to be douche bags.
Okay.
Let's not speak in absolutes here.
Why the fuck would I say shit like that on the Goddamn Memorial Day?
You know what,
I support all the troops,
even at Douche bags today,
but on any other day,
I don't.
I,
you know,
I live in,
I live in the real world.
Here am or not.
I don't live in a real world.
Look at me.
I'm fucking sitting here with an orange microphone talking shit to fucking
myself.
I'm a realist.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Look at and look at all,
what's his face there,
George Bush.
You know what I mean?
I bet people didn't think he was a Douche bag.
I bet he was a hot shit when he was in the fucking national guard.
You know,
taking weekends off when he's supposed to be there and probably took you out on
his boat.
Now,
I didn't have a boat.
He lived in Texas.
Probably had a horse or some shit.
Isn't it amazing how that,
that guy just,
he just fucking disappeared.
You know,
I didn't,
I didn't agree with George Bush's policies,
but there was just something about that guy that I just really fucking related
to.
You know what I mean?
Like if I s w if I stopped being president,
the amount of stress that has to be involved with that fucking job,
I gotta tell you something,
Dude,
today that job was over.
I,
that's that.
Yeah,
I'd be like him.
You'd never see me again,
or the very least I would take like a
God,
I,
you'd have to,
you'd have to take at least five fucking years off.
I know.
If they told stories about how much that job ages you,
and if you don't believe it,
look at like younger pictures of George Bush.
Like how quickly you go.
Gray.
Same thing happen to,
uh,
to Bill Clinton.
You know?
Or maybe they just stop using Grecian formula because they,
they got elected and I'm like,
well,
I don't have to do this fucking beauty parlors shit.
Anyways,
I got the fucking job.
You know,
I'm taking my dick out,
bringing in an intern.
One of the easiest impressions ever.
Build a little Bill Clinton for you.
You like that.
And then in the end of this,
I'll do a Vinnie Barbarino.
Actually,
no,
let's,
one of the things that I wish I knew how to do,
I wish I knew how to do a impressions.
I wish,
I wish I could do it.
I can more sort of imitate people who I hang out with,
but I can't imitate famous people.
And unless somebody famous already does the impression,
then I can do an impression of their impression.
That's basically it.
You know,
that's,
that's I'm sort of a hacky impression guy.
And a,
and then if you do something really obscure,
which I think I've talked to before in this podcast,
like a j Moore's Collin Quinn,
if you guys seen that,
I'm going to cross promote right now,
not only j more,
but the opion Anthony show go on youtube and a searched Jay Mohr,
opie and Anthony and uh,
he calls in,
he does a series of unbelievable fucking impressions.
And the most amazing one is he does Colin Quinn.
And if you know,
who the fuck does that guy?
Like I've known Collin Forever and I've never noticed any like ticking the way
he talks and this guy,
you know what I mean as this,
like one time I saw somebody do a,
the first person I saw do Tom cruise the fuck show was I watching?
I was watching.
It wasn't 30 rock.
Excuse me.
How to clear my throat wasn't 30 rock.
What was that other show that that dude from friends was on that was like 30
rock except they were taking it seriously.
What the fuck was that one called?
Like 60 degrees.
I can never remember these.
I die.
It wasn't there a number in it,
you know,
to find Jesus Christ.
We have to do a sketch show.
Is that what it's called?
I know it was a drama but whatever.
But there was some kid in there who did impressions accuse fucking unreal.
He did a Ben Stiller and a uh,
and a Tom cruise that we're dead on.
And I,
I've scoured the internet trying to find scoured.
Is that,
is that really a fucking,
does that the right word?
Does that mean you got burned now?
Scalded is burned.
Scoured,
that's not a fucking word.
Whatever.
I searched high and low near and far all over the Internet.
I can't fucking find it,
but it's definitely worth a,
it's definitely worth checking out and a,
and there you go.
I've talked myself into a corner.
I don't know what the fuck to say now.
I just realized that usually I just,
you know,
I get a head of steam going,
this is how I do these podcasts.
I get a fucking head of steam going and I just start running until I'm out of
breath.
And then I go back to the screen and,
and,
and I read like questions or whatever.
But you know what?
I'm not going to read a question this week.
I'm going to start off with the,
a couple of stories about dogs.
All right?
One funny one in one feel good.
One for the Memorial Day holiday.
All right,
here we go.
Ah,
this comes from some fucking,
dude.
I don't name names on this.
All right.
I'm old school.
Uh,
hey bill,
I have a dog story for you.
Uh,
whenever I visit my parents who live at the Jersey shore,
I always take my dog who lives with them to the beach.
Uh,
personally,
I love that sentence.
Listen to this.
Whenever I visit my parents who live in the Jersey shore,
I always take my dog who lives with them to the beach.
Dude,
if your dog lives with your parents,
that's not your dog.
All right?
That's like,
you know,
that's like you banged,
you'd fucking knocked up your 16 year old girlfriend and you left the baby with
your parents and they raised it.
You know,
you a run to one.
Those douchebags in a bar.
If fucking two in the morning on a Wednesday starts saying how he's got a kid.
Yeah,
we see my kid
[inaudible] he takes out a picture of it,
you know,
and it's like,
dude,
it's fucking 2:00 AM on a Wednesday.
Shouldn't you be home with your kid?
Ah,
yeah,
I don't have it right now.
She's with my parents.
Well then it's not your fucking kid.
All right.
Yet you're like a,
you're like his brother sold a brother who's out,
like,
like chuck on happy days.
Anybody remember that?
How many people out there realize that Richie Cunningham actually had an older
brother during the first season named chuck and he didn't know what the fuck to
do with them.
So they just had them go off to college and then they just never used them
again.
And then after while they literally started just saying that they got two kids
and they never address that kid anymore,
you know,
ever again.
That's what your fucking dogs life sir.
It's like chuck on happy days.
But anyways,
let's read the rest of the story because this is actually a funny story.
Uh,
my dog is 110 pound golden retriever who basically looks like a furry keg with
legs.
Goddamn.
And I can't fucking read it.
So anyways,
so I had my dog at the beach and his favorite thing to do with the beaches to go
in the water and swim after tennis balls.
Uh,
so one day I'm at the beach and this is school trip of what seems to be a fourth
graders or fifth graders.
And they're looking at see life in a jetty.
Sir.
I like how you wrote jetty.
Like everybody knows what the fuck a jetty is.
What does a jetty,
is that a little pool of water that gathers during high tide and then remains
during low tide?
Is that what a jetty is?
I don't know.
I know it's not a lagoon cause I watched Gilligan's island.
All right.
Uh,
so a few of the kids came up to me and asked me if it was okay if they could
play with my dog.
So I told him no problem.
And the kids are getting a kick out of watch my dog run to the water and fetch
the tennis ball.
So one of the kids yells over to his friend who's busy looking in the jetty.
He's like,
hey dude,
you've gotta come over here and check out how cool this dog it.
At which point the kid in the looking in the jetty says,
no way you guys are missing out.
There's a whole bunch of crustaceans over here.
So the kid who's standing next to me just sort of turns and looks at me and
goes,
what a faggot.
And I just burst out laughing because I was thinking the exact same thing
adds a fucking hilarious story right there.
People,
I don't know if it went by you,
but that was a funny God damn story.
That's the funny thing about being an adult if you're younger.
Yeah.
I guess you think that,
you know you're going to get mature and you're not gonna think that shit that
you would have thought in fourth grade.
And that's not what being an adult is being adult is,
I guess,
still thinking the same shit that a fourth grader thinks.
But you gotta act like you're not thinking.
You know,
like,
I'd like to think if I was there,
I would have said,
uh,
you know,
you shouldn't use that word.
It's very offensive,
uh,
Bababa and gone down that politically correct route.
But I probably would have left too.
You know what I mean?
And that was just funny on a lot of levels where the kid was being a little
pussy.
And the fact that a fourth grader would say that and the fact that it's coming
out of a fourth graders mouth,
you know what I mean?
I,
I would challenge one of those politically correct people.
You know,
I don't,
I,
you know what,
I just talked myself into a fucking corner again,
I don't know what to say.
This is one of these deals,
you know,
it is really people,
I had a big argument,
my girlfriend,
and she's walking the dog right now and I know she's coming back in a half hour
and she's worked,
she's going to come in and she's not going to argue with me.
Okay.
For you douchebags that think you're going to get a little behind the scenes
here,
my relationship.
But she's definitely got to give me the silent treatment and as much as I'm
going to try to block her out,
it's a,
I'm not going to be able to do it because her silence is just going to be
fucking washing over me,
you know?
So whatever.
Um,
I had one of those arguments you have,
you have to have in a relationship.
Every once in awhile he got to blow the air out of the pipes and,
uh,
that's what I did and I'm going to be paying for it today.
So I hope your guys Memorial Day is working out a little better than mine.
What do you think about that?
Okay.
And how about a little pat on the back for me on a nice fucking holiday,
actually doing this God damn podcast has 17 fucking free minutes so far.
I gotta tell you I'm not doing 50 minutes.
I know.
I always say that,
but I'm not doing it this week.
Okay?
I got shit to do.
I've got laundry going.
All right,
I've got a whole bunch of shit I got to do before I can then go to a goddamn
barbecue show off my pasty white legs and have a burger because that's what the
fuck I'm doing.
Um,
so anyways,
you know,
before I get too far down the road,
that is a new,
that is a new segment here where you have to tell a bad story about a group of
people that just consistently always gets good press and don't fucking make one
up either.
Okay.
If you have one,
send one in.
If you don't,
please don't waste my time.
People always try and do that.
Like I don't read a lot of the shit that people send me cause it's just,
you know,
some of the revenge stories,
that's why I kind of stopped doing it because they really got like ridiculous,
you know,
they started getting like James Bond ask and I might do the overhead of this
revenge is six figures.
Okay.
This didn't happen.
So anyways,
yeah.
If he,
if you knew,
you know,
a nun who was being a little cunty one day,
uh,
who else gets good press?
Kids get great press.
You know,
like they can do no wrong like they have,
they're not aware that they're doing wrong.
You know,
I don't know if you don't hate kids on some level,
you just not being honest with yourself.
All right.
Um,
what have we got here?
Let's go with the,
uh,
the questions for the week.
All right.
Question number one,
Bill.
Uh,
if you had the choice to resurrect either resurrect,
either bond Scott,
Jimi Hendrix or John Bonam for one night,
who would you want to see in concert?
Uh,
you son of a bitch.
That's a hard one.
Um,
huge ACDC fan and I've always hated the fact that I never got to see bond Scott,
but Jimi Hendrix,
that would be like being able to see fucking,
uh,
I can't even say Jordan cause I got to see him play.
I would tell you that story when I saw,
uh,
Michael Jordan play,
I saw him in North Carolina and that when he played with the tar heels,
this is a story for people who live in North Carolina because I in this,
in the place was not packed.
I might've told this story before.
I can't even fucking remember.
I talk on my cell phone so much.
My brain's mush basically.
I was living in North Carolina in 87,
88.
And uh,
it was a year before the Charlotte Hornets,
we're going to start in the NBA.
So to get people excited about a NBA hoop,
you know,
cause obviously down there they got to a backhoe road and all that fucking shit.
They're really big into college ball to get people excited.
What they did was they had to scrimmages at the Dean Dome at the University of
North Carolina.
And um,
what they did was they had a basically two games of professional hoop,
like scrimmage hoop and each team had a former tar heel on it.
And one of the Games was a,
the Chicago Bulls verse.
I want to say the Cleveland Cavaliers.
So you had Michael Jordan,
former tar heel and then you had Brad Doherty on the Cavaliers.
And uh,
so I've,
I've got to see Michael Jordan back when he was skinny and he had hair and he,
and he only had one dunk,
but it was cool.
It was so early.
I told this story before,
I remember that I told this story before.
It didn't I or did I tell it in a bar?
I can't fucking remember.
But I remember it was so early in Jordan's career,
I was nudging my mom going this,
watch that guy.
That guy's good.
You know that guy's good.
Can you fucking believe that?
And then the other game was the Los Angeles Lakers cause they had James worthy
former tar heel.
And I want to say they played the Seattle Supersonics and it was a Sam Perkins,
but I can't fuck I remember.
So if anybody from North Carolina or if you can Google it and somehow it was in
the dean dome.
I remember that.
I do remember that.
And it wasn't nearly,
it was,
it was probably three quarters full,
not even maybe 60% fucking full.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Can I get back to the fucking questionnaire?
All right.
Bonds,
Scott,
Jimi Hendrix man or John Bonam.
Ah,
fuck.
You know,
I can't,
I can't fucking answer that.
John Bonam Moba Deck
Jimi Hendrix.
Well,
I'll tell you yes,
if I was going to see,
you know what?
I would have to flip a coin,
which doesn't even work out mathematically because his three fucking people,
I'd have to throw a dart.
All right.
I got to MIT.
Bon Scott is out.
God dammit.
I never thought I'd say that.
Okay.
But the thing about Jimmy Hendrickson,
John Bonam is they,
they changed
Jimi Hendrix changed fucking what you thought was what you could do on the
guitar and John Barnum,
you know,
basically he brought rock drumming into the modern era.
So fucking can't,
what a question.
All right,
now this is all I can tell you.
I would throw a dart between Jimmy Hendrickson,
John Bonam,
and when I would see Jimi Hendrix,
it would be with band of Gypsies,
not with the experience.
All right?
Cause that,
uh,
that live album,
he has [inaudible] we plays machine gun and all that shit.
[inaudible] Ba da Ba da Ba da Ba du bad.
That one with Bob.
I was at buddy miles on drums in a Billy Cox,
whatever his fucking name is on base that I would,
I'd want,
that's what I wanted.
I would want to see him on at that,
wherever they take that.
Was it in San Francisco at the Fillmore,
remember that shit.
And I would see John Bonam at a Royal Albert Hall and I would be backstage and I
would be able to see his fucking based from fourth to figure out what the fuck
he was doing.
Do you guys ever listen to old live albums or you ever watch old concert footage
of how polite rock shows where like the promoter would literally come out and
they,
they would like announced the band like on that Jimi Hendrix one,
it's really cool.
Like this promoter comes out and people have this little polite apar applause
and a,
the here this for murder going out,
you know,
welcome to the Fillmore west tonight.
We have a wonderful new band.
Ah,
Babababa Blah,
all this type of shit.
And in the background,
Jimmy's already playing.
He says
[inaudible] and the fucking promoter is talking over it.
It gives me chill the second he's done,
then they just fucking go into the song.
You know?
Maybe because I'm old now,
I would love to go see a great band and be able to sit down and just fucking
enjoy them as musicians.
I hate the fact that I have to fucking stand up,
you know,
and look around that Douche bag,
who puts his fucking girlfriend on his shoulders?
You want to talk about a fucking pussy whipped individual.
It's already bad enough that you probably had to buy the fucking tickets.
You had to pay for parking.
You're already fucking whatever,
two,
300 bucks in the hall,
you know?
And then on top of that,
you've got to put your fucking chick on your shoulders,
right?
See,
you're literally,
your spinal cord is crunching down so she can get up there and make eyes over
there with the fucking lead singer and possibly even flash your tits that she'll
then fucking blame on whatever the weed was fucking laced with.
You're actually helping her to maybe bang another guy at that point.
You know,
because it's the lead singer likes her.
He just gives the nod to the fucking,
the,
uh,
his go gather some pussy guy.
And then when he comes down there and he taps your girlfriend on the shoulder,
says he wants to meet him,
you know,
you sitting there going like,
you want to say no,
you can't do that.
But you know,
you're never going to hear the end of it because that was a dream to go see a
fucking I Eddie fucking Douche bag,
whatever his fucking name is Eddie vetter.
Right.
I,
you know,
I totally lost control of that story because my washing machine just started
beeping to let me know that the a load of clothes has done.
This is what I'm doing with my fucking,
my memorial day all listen to the sirens.
You know,
be funny if I could actually do this,
this podcast live.
And that was a bunch of firemen coming over here to kick my ass,
you know,
and just to be traditional,
they didn't break down the door with an ax.
They actually put the ladder up just to confuse me.
Jesus Christ is my house on fire.
Here it comes.
It would have that moment
and there it goes.
Ah,
right.
He's winded down.
Okay,
keep going.
Jesus Christ thought my place was on fire there for a second.
Um,
anyways,
so that's what I would do.
I would pick between Jimmy Hendrickson Bon Scott and I would throw a dart and
uh,
I have to admit,
I think I would see Jimi Hendrix in the end of it there,
I made my decision.
I would see Jimi Hendrix.
Dude,
that was a great fucking question.
That really was a great question.
Here comes another goddamn truck.
You know what?
This is some douchebag on memorial day already burned down their fucking
backyard with their,
with their Hibachi Jesus Christ.
There's the one where you got to steer in the back.
Holy Shit,
this,
stop it on my street.
What would you do with the middle of this fucking podcast?
All of a sudden somebody came on while we're like a megaphone,
Marie Tangerine bind everybody on the street,
eighth to evacuate.
Do you know that happened to me when I was a kid?
Jesus Christ is for fucking fire trucks right outside my window.
I feel like one of those guys,
I feel like Jimmy Olsen,
like I'm getting the scoop right now.
You know what?
Now I have to go over and I have to investigate.
Let me bring my little fucking podcast station over here.
You know,
it'd be great if there was one right below the window and I could actually stick
my head out with,
I actually wear headphones and I got this microphone with the orange screen on
it
and I just started talking like it was the 1920s scares me.
Sad.
What's going on down there?
Trying to get the scope.
Why can't I open my fucking windows?
You know what's funny?
Do you ever notice like whenever like some fucking old lady twists are goddamn
ankle,
like 17 firetrucks show up.
It's like,
is it really necessary?
Why don't you put all the the old lady broker fucking hip shit on one truck,
dude,
there's no smoke.
There's nothing.
There's four fucking fire trucks
for fire trucks.
Oh my God.
Is that a,
Oh that is a woman.
I thought that was a guy.
Jesus Christ.
Somebody just came walking by
looking like they were in one of those,
you know,
those eighties bands that just uh,
they all just had like,
you know,
the one hit wonders,
but there was,
there was,
there was that whole scene like they weren't like Duran Duran.
They actually thought like,
they were like artistic.
What the,
what the fuck kind of bands were those.
They weren't,
it wasn't like heavy metal.
It wasn't rock,
um,
new wave.
That's right.
I thought it was some guy dressed like he was front a new wave band and ended up
just being,
I didn't,
you know,
you know when girls like put their,
their,
their ponytail,
you know,
and they wrap it around the front and you can't fucking see it.
Dude,
there's no sense of urgency.
Now they're backing the fire truck up.
I want this is,
this is one of these times when I just wish I was old so I could go out there
and just start yelling at him.
You know,
about taxpayers money and Shit,
dude have fucked up is that I was making fun of firemen,
you know,
at the beginning of this podcast.
And for fucking fire show up.
You know what?
This is the thing.
I have to close the window because my voice really carries and I say fuck a lot.
Not to mention the word cunt,
so I'm going to have to,
you know when they always leave the fire engines running,
you know?
Who Do you think pays for that gas?
Huh?
We do
say this is great.
This is the new segment right here.
I can trash fireman if there's a fire man.
Listen right now,
is that a fire man or a fireman?
You know,
if one of you motherfuckers is listening right now,
can you answer that?
Why?
When there's no smoke,
there's no fire.
Why do 18 trucks show up?
You guys all just bored or you're trying to get away from that.
Get that,
that the fat fuck down the firehouse.
Who's making the Chili?
You know,
isn't that,
isn't there like always there was always a cook down there,
isn't there?
He's got one of those big mustaches.
Hey,
what do you make it today?
They have Freddy.
Oh,
Megan.
Some fucking Chile.
Really?
You're going to make some give famous fucking red hot chili and then I'm going
to have had that in my mouth and I'm,
I going to go fight a fucking fire.
You asshole.
I bought some Koolaid.
Now I'm fascinated.
Can you hear the rumble of those engines?
You know a lot of checks like firemen,
they do to some about him.
You know,
they rescue people,
you know,
they that raincoat
sort of perverted.
It's like,
you know,
they naked under there.
Is he going to show?
Is it going to show me his hose?
There's a,
there's a bunch of them walking around and they have fucking rain coats.
Jesus Christ.
You know something I gotta admit.
You know what?
I wouldn't,
I would walk out on my balcony.
I actually have a little fucking balcony I could be standing on right now.
I could figure out what the fuck's going on.
I,
I can't even do the rest of this podcast.
This is ridiculous.
Was that really me talking?
I just wants to some accent there.
I usually say,
this is ridiculous.
This is ridiculous.
Um,
all right,
I'm going to try to fucking answer the rest of these questions is for fire
trucks.
Sit outside and people walk around.
Is it a chemical spill?
All right.
That concludes part one.
And I have no idea why there's such a huge echo on this.
I'm using the,
uh,
the recorder from my,
my fucking laptop,
so that ends part one.
Now just go listen to part two just in case you're a complete moron and you
didn't know that that's what you were supposed to do.
Okay.
Hey,
what's up?
This is bill burr and this is part two of the Monday morning podcasts from May
25th,
2009.
And for the life of me,
I don't know what that fucking echo was all about.
Um,
oh yeah,
started to tell the story yet,
when I was a kid,
uh,
this fucking guy's barn burned down and evidently he ran this big business and
he had toxics toxic waste and these big oil drums.
So evidently they went around to every house in the neighborhood,
knocking on the door,
telling everybody to get the fuck out of their house.
And I don't know if they forgot to go to our house or what,
but we didn't know.
We didn't know.
So me and my brother went out to do our paper routes in the morning.
That's how white my childhood was.
You know,
right after I had a piece of toast with that little square piece of butter on
it.
I went out
part of this complete breakfast after I had my complete breakfast,
I went out to do my paper route and there was all this smoke in the air and
there was nobody.
We lived on a busy street and there were no cars and there was just this
firehose going all the way up right down the middle of the street.
So we will let a wheel like,
oh wow,
that's cool.
Right?
We didn't give a fuck.
So,
uh,
I ride my bike down the street to do my first customer,
which is in the direction of the fire.
So I drove down there on my bicycle and there's a fireman standing there and
he's got,
you know,
the,
the fucking oxygen mask on.
And he literally looks at me and he did literally the cartoon doubletake like
Yeti,
yet it,
it,
you know,
like what the fleet,
like he couldn't believe what he was saying.
There's all his smoker here.
Here I come up,
my little howdy doody face comes up to street riding on my little bicycle and he
comes and he starts screaming at me through that mass going like your grandma
[inaudible]
just dropping the f bomb and I'll be like,
I have a paper route.
I had no idea.
So we ended up,
uh,
you know,
maybe that's why my memory sucks cause I sat there breathing in,
breathe in,
all that shit.
Allegedly the guy who's who,
uh,
whose barn it was started radio shack.
That was,
that was the,
uh,
that was the rumor.
So anyways,
here we go.
Ah,
question number two.
Hey Bill,
I want to know what you think of old people going,
going to the gym.
Every time I see this 60 year old guy doing sit ups at the gym,
I feel sorry for him.
I work out so I can stay healthy and live to see old age.
Once I see old age,
it's mission accomplished,
right?
I think one,
uh,
when I see these old people,
I think one or two things is going on.
Either he doesn't know he's old,
which is pathetic or he wants to grow older,
which is even more pathetic.
I mean,
how selfish can you be?
Do you want your family to be wiping your ass at 90?
The big question is,
at what age will you stop working out?
I'm done at 50.
I got 18 more years to go.
Uh,
thanks for the podcast.
they help my three hour daily commute.
Make it much easier.
Well,
thank you,
sir.
I'm glad you like them.
Um,
don't you hate when somebody calls you serve by the way,
our,
ma'am,
isn't that the worst?
The first day that that fucking happens?
You just like Jesus,
I really am old.
Okay.
When am I going to stop working out?
Uh,
I got to met,
dude.
I'm never going to stop working out,
but I won't be going to the gym.
Maybe I will be.
You know what,
I,
I've just,
I just sort of,
I've adjusted my workouts to,
uh,
to with my age.
Like I used to,
I used to,
you know,
I used to throw the weights around over there.
Oh right.
And,
uh,
you know,
used to play full court hoop running up and down,
but my body just can't take that.
I can still lift weights and shit.
I just get bored doing that.
But,
uh,
as I grow older,
I,
I've told myself that I'm gradually gonna Morph into yoga and pilates.
I just paused there way
February fool.
You yogo you fucking gays solve to where you stretching yourself out as you can
give welcome bang in the air.
You are gonna do.
Guys are so fucking dumb,
you know?
And it's just something about anytime you do something smart,
immediately it's considered feminine.
You know,
if you do something dumb,
you're a man.
If you don't work out and he keeps drinking red bear shovin half a fucking cow's
head into your colon,
then Dan,
Dan,
you're a guy.
But yeah,
that's what I'm going to do it.
And No,
I'm not gonna.
No,
I'm never stuck.
I'm going to stop working out.
I'm never going to stop trying new things and trying to learn shit because when
you do that shit,
dude,
you die.
You Die.
And it's very easily to be 32 I've done the math.
You're 32 years old.
It's very easy to say that.
You know you're going to say fuck it at 50 you're not dude,
because the 32 if you're still working out,
that means you still look good,
which means women are still kind of check in.
You are.
But I'm telling you,
dude,
it starts dropping off and when it starts fucking dropping off,
you know,
you're like,
Jesus Christ,
I don't even fucking look at me anymore.
And it's,
it's going to motivate you or you'll just go into a depression and you,
we'll spoon with that depression and you'll eat yourself into an early grave
before you're 50 so those are your options.
All right,
hang in that dual,
keep working out.
You know,
you want to come that,
do you want to come that to that fat?
Fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
We got that big bulge of fat right above your deck.
You don't want to be that guy.
You know,
he just,
you know,
you get that old person,
I'm going to die soon.
Smell that's just bad.
You don't,
you don't want to be that guy.
All right.
Uh,
you know,
just out of curiosity,
I wonder who the oldest person is who actually listens to this fucking podcast.
You know,
that's another thing.
I always want to stay up on music and that type of shit.
I think that's easy to do when you don't have children,
but,
uh,
I don't fucking know.
Fail.
Just shut up and move on with the questions.
I'll right.
Question number three,
Bill.
I'm from Cleveland.
Uh,
and I've wrote was really s and I'm really psyched about the,
uh,
Cavalier Orlando's Wednesday game.
It was amazing.
He had a bit dis pressing at the same time.
Fortunately the Cavs lost one oh seven one oh six dip protect the day or the
whole way through.
Uh,
do you think Lebron will lead the Cavaliers to victory against the magic?
And who do you anticipate to win the championship?
Um,
I have to admit,
I don't know shit about basketball.
And I've started to watch now that the Bruins and the Celtics are knocked out.
You know,
I wasn't really even watching the Celtics.
I'm just not in the hoop.
And,
uh,
I got to met,
you know,
Cleveland,
Orlando,
I don't think you could ask for a better series all but Lakers,
Denver,
that series has sucked.
It's like neither team has won a game yet.
Denver blew the first game,
the Lakers blue,
the second game,
and Denver blew the third game.
And,
um,
what's killing me is that I don't see a dominant fucking team in the four
remaining team.
So I think this is kind of,
it's kind of a weak year.
I think Lebron is the shit.
And I think that fucking superhero do there.
What Howard for Orlando is ridiculous and Kobe's ridiculous.
And what's his face?
Carmelo Anthony is ridiculous.
And everyone else is regular.
That just regular standing around watching those guys doing shit,
you know?
Hey,
we go.
That'll get me a lot of fucking emails.
All these fucking who?
Peds,
dude.
Oh fuck.
Can you say that?
Stood fucking
chummy,
whatever,
fucking whatever some black guy name is fucking regular.
He had,
he had 22 week loan,
70 seats.
I don't give a fuck.
Pro Hoop is fucking boring.
The referees control the tempo or the game and the final three minutes takes an
hour.
Fuck that game.
Okay,
what does that,
what does that thing that that the commercial that they have,
when's the next time great will happen?
I'll tell you when the ref stops blowing his fucking whistle.
Every five seconds.
Do the second one team goes into the penalty.
Just kiss the rest of your day.
Goodbye.
It is the most boring fucking hundred points you're ever going to see in your
life.
Colby Ryan shooting the front end of a one on one.
He's 38 or 39 from the line tonight.
39 38 39 let's fucking divide that by two.
That's fucking what?
1819 there'll be night.
They'd be his 20th fucking time.
He's gone to the line 20 fucking times at that point.
And Miss,
oh no.
18 wait,
can you be 38 39 yeah,
cause you could,
you could go for three point play.
So whatever.
The guy's gone on line,
like fucking anywhere from 16 to 20 fucking times,
20 fucking times.
They blown the whistle with one fucking guy.
All right.
I know 38 is a high number.
Okay.
But there's nights where he's,
you know,
20 or 22 from the line.
It's one guy,
one guy is stopped the game 10 fucking times.
It's,
it's,
it's the worst.
And I got to Mit,
I think pro football really gets boring.
You know,
there's nothing worse than a pro football game against two teams that are
mediocre.
It's just terrible.
And it's one of the written other reasons why I love hockey,
because at the very least,
have two teams suck.
Maybe there'll be a fight,
you know,
any other sport,
if there's a fight that is the lead fucking story on sports center.
Holy Shit,
the benches emptied or this guy charged them out of fucking whatever.
And hockey is whatever that can happen in any game to Goddamn great sport.
If you like the movie Mad Max and you don't like hockey and you're very
inconsistent human being.
All right,
let's get on with computer tips.
Uh,
we've been doing very basic computer tips,
helping people like myself are limp along.
And,
uh,
just to get shit moving here,
I have to admit,
this person brought in some computer tips this week.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five of them in the first four.
I knew.
So a few guys,
you know,
all you guys who are really into computer,
if you guys can,
can go to the next level here where we can talk about preferences,
you know,
where you know,
they click on the apple and then Click on preferences,
go into the applications and if you can break down that shit,
um,
that would really help me out because I'm really getting good at computers right
now or much better than I was because you guys,
so I appreciate it.
So here's the A,
okay.
My girlfriend's back.
Now it's going to get awkward.
It's going to get awkward.
Um,
all right,
here are some of the uh,
the questions here.
Uh,
question number,
uh,
or some of the computer tips.
Computer tip number one.
Uh,
hold the apple command and the letter x to cut.
I mean people know this shit.
Apple Command and the letter C to copy Apple Command and the letter V to paste.
And this is the one I didn't know.
Apple Command and the letter Z to undo.
I didn't know that one.
And that one.
Basically this guy so eloquently puts when you just fucked up any document,
email or typing that you just did,
if you delete something by accident and then hit the,
just hit apple z and you get it back.
Um,
and he goes,
God,
I know you have to know the f three button to separate the screens by now,
but I just want to make sure since that shit is on the Mac,
you know what dude,
I didn't know that one f three.
You hit that and that separates all your windows,
which at which point I said,
what is that for?
Do?
And that's when I found the calculator,
the date,
my forecast for the week and the time.
So that's pretty fucking cool.
I'll actually have to start the podcast with that.
So I won't know the dates but,
and for anyone,
you know,
I'm kind of be an arrogant ass here cause I am a moron.
So if you don't know shit like that,
that apple command and the letter x,
uh,
is basically when you just highlight whatever you just did,
if you hit the command button and let her ex that will just delete the sentence,
you know,
apple,
see that will copy it.
And then Apple v you paste it to somewhere else.
It's very easy to figure out.
But um,
I think at this point everybody's caught up.
So if you guys do computer tips,
if you want to take them to the next level,
that would be greatly appreciated and all you fucking Douche bags out there who
are good at computer,
just so fucking basic,
this shit that you suck at,
right?
Okay.
Look at me getting all defensive.
All right.
You want to hear a heart warming dog story and I'll end the podcast here and
actually I want,
I'm going to blow through some underrated overrated because a lot of people sent
some shit in.
Okay.
Heartwarming dog story.
Uh,
oh.
And also I,
I gotta have Douche bag of the week.
I forgot about that one.
Heartwarming dog story.
Uh,
all right,
Bill,
you've probably gotten a lot of emails.
We're going,
Doug,
I have a dog that we found five years ago.
I was driving home after work and I saw a yellow lab mix in the middle of the
road.
She was running across a busy street with an e color on one of those things.
The vet's put on a dog and uh,
I dunno,
fucking dog has been [inaudible].
This is a really long stories.
So she's running across the street and nobody was stopping.
She was really scared and confused,
running all over the street.
Everyone was honking their horns and she was just running back and forth.
Not sure where to go.
Basically,
she was freaking out.
So I saw in the middle,
in the midsection of the street waiting to turn.
When I saw her,
I call her to come over,
which he did,
and I opened my car door and yanked her in the car.
Dude,
you got more balls than me.
I would definitely feel bad for the dog,
but I saw old yeller at the wrong age and I've never just like jaws.
I saw jaws when I was young and I will not go into the ocean and if there's a
fucking stray dog freaking out,
I'm not going to Yank it in my car for fear of getting rabies.
Um,
I quickly noticed she had a surgical scar on her stomach.
This dog was scared and she had the most desperate looking arise.
It really shook me.
So I brought her home and I put her in the yard while I got our dogs put in
place where they wouldn't see each other.
Since I didn't know how this dog would behave.
See,
this guy really knows about dogs here.
I quickly found that she was terrified and we're not leave my site.
She would come over to me and sit on my feet and follow me everywhere I went.
So we put her in a different room away from our other dog and my wife and I got
a plan together to find her owner.
Uh,
she was so sweet and terrified.
she must need to get back to her house with her owners.
Right.
So we put up signs and went around to neighbor's house.
How's the house?
Door to door to see if we can find the owner.
No luck.
The next day my wife went to the nearest vet office because we figured that's
where she had a surgery done.
Well,
they had never seen her before,
but said a,
the vet,
the vet said he wanted to scan her for uh,
a microchip.
Turns out she had one and she was from a no kill shelter.
So we called the shelter.
She was from,
turns out they kept her at a veterinarian's house down the street,
but Baba Baba Baba and uh,
they said that they would come over and pick her up,
but by this time I was having second thoughts.
After only two days or other dog had taken tours as well as well.
Um,
there's,
Doug loved me after only two days and I can't explain it because my other dog
could care less about me.
Um,
it's my wife's dog and I,
um,
and don't get me wrong,
I love him,
but this was different.
This dog somehow got into my heart.
See,
this is what happened with Cleo.
I got the dog and after two days I fucking loved the dog.
Um,
so anyways,
the vet told us,
uh,
her story,
which was verified later on by the shelter rep who came to approve us,
uh,
to adopt her for a home.
It turns out she was given up.
I'm really fucking flake in here.
It turns out she was given up by everyone in the families that adopted her.
She was adopted five times.
Do that's not a red light flashing.
She was adopted five times and they keep getting rid of her.
Anyways,
over the years she's developed some minor behavioral issues such as digging and
getting out of the yard.
She was placed in when left alone.
Um,
but whatever her name is Bella,
and while she was a pain in the ass at the time,
she is,
as you said,
what I come home to.
And uh,
basically the dude actually loves the dog and rest of the dog and says,
congrats on Cleo.
What?
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
You know,
I don't know.
There is something really cool I guess about rescuing a dog,
but there are a lot of,
if you're a realist,
there's a lot of red flags there.
Dog had been adopted five fucking times.
Uh,
you know,
I dunno.
It's a great thing.
God bless you if he adopted dark.
All right,
let's get onto douche bag of the week.
All right.
His douche bag of the week.
Some reason this person sends me this email right in the middle of my day.
Hey Bill,
nice move.
Assuming I'm a female,
I guess I read one of this dispersant uh,
questions and I assumed that they were a female so they got all upset going.
Nice move.
Assuming I'm a female,
since I never sign my name.
And when you read my comments on your podcast and always refer to me as a male,
it's just interesting how people will determine if a person is male or female
without ever meeting them and just reading what they write.
Why can't a woman writes something about baseball or hockey?
Uh,
say saying something true,
saying some true overrated shit without being assumed.
A male.
And uh,
this is after she,
the first email she wrote,
she wrote,
Bill,
fuck you.
And then I wrote,
Hey Sweetie,
happy Monday to you.
Okay.
So then she sends me this other email,
you know,
eh,
it's just really interesting how,
and people then emails without ever meeting them.
They ask them whether they're male or female.
So I just wrote back really,
you know,
that's it.
That's all that deserved really.
You know what I mean?
First of all,
sweetheart,
I don't know if you realize it,
but in the subject area,
up top it has your full name,
which is a female name.
And I don't know if you realize this,
but I get a ton of fucking emails and I don't say people's names,
so I delete the names and I just read them.
Okay.
And at that point,
I don't know whether it's male or female,
it's not a fucking sexist thing.
You fucking psychopath.
I keep referring to my dog as a male because I fucking always had male dogs.
My girlfriend keeps giving me shit.
I go,
I got to take them out.
And she's like her,
you know?
But it's not like,
you know,
I wouldn't hire you if you had the right.
What a fucking,
you're a Douche bag.
All right.
You're a big fucking Douche.
But you know,
you're such a big douchebag that literally 12 other Douche bags could climb in
your douche bag.
That's how big a fucking Douche bag you were.
Okay.
And that,
assuming anything,
I get a ton of fucking emails.
And if somebody writes about hockey,
yeah,
I do assume that they're fucking mail the same way.
If somebody wrote about crocheting a fucking Afghan,
I would assume that there are female,
I wouldn't be trying to insult the Rosey Greer fucking guy who's into knitting.
Just generally speaking.
That's a fucking a,
that's a female thing to do.
All right.
Doesn't mean I don't respect you and your vagina and your knowledge about
hockey.
You know,
you know what,
from now on,
I'm just gonna.
I'm gonna fucking a,
I'm going to say the gender of everybody.
All right.
Like here's an email from someone who has a Dick.
Uh,
just a quick notes in regards to the caveman killer.
Remember last week,
the serial killer thing,
uh,
using a sharpened stick as a weapon and then burning it is a,
so there would be no evidence.
Uh,
there's a bit of a problem here,
although it's genius and inventive and inventive way to do it.
He would get caught.
Um,
when the autopsy was performed,
they would come across the fibers,
dirt and residue left behind by said stick.
They would then do an analysis on the residue to find out what,
what it was composed of and what type of tree was used to make Swiss cheese of
the victim.
Now having that information,
the authorities would then plot out a map of every single area within the state
or a vicinity of the victim to narrow down where the stick could have come from.
They would then Jesus crisis as long.
They would then narrowed down that further based on the composition of the dirt
in any traces of nutrients and figure out exactly where the,
what area of the stick came from.
A mass search would then take place and set area and more likely they would be
able to pinpoint the spot where the earth was disturbed or the branch that was
broken within a 24 to 48 hour window concluding that this is the spot where the
weapon was obtained.
They were then probably find fibers from the clothing of the perpetrator so they
would match that.
Later after putting out a new story with the evidence,
they had someone to come forward saying they saw a car or a person in the area
that seemed to be out of place.
Sketchy sketch drawing would be done and released.
The and the caveman killer would be located and arrested putting a nice tight
bow on the case would be their ability to match the dirt from the spot where the
weapon was found in the,
to the dirt,
found on the bottom of the shoes that were in the garage of said caveman killer.
Further investigation in the vehicle would find more traces of that dirt on the
floor mats from the shoes and on the seat where the weapon was placed on the way
to the op,
the offing,
sorry to say Mr Cave.
Sorry to say Mister Caveman.
Game over.
Have Fun playing.
Hide the stick in prison over the next 50 years to life.
Jesus Christ.
You've got to give it up to that guy for breaking it down.
I know he's kind of a,
he was only semi-serious there.
He's talking about like those fucking a and e murder things.
Cause that's literally how people get caught.
Like Sasol one with this guy suffocated,
somebody with a,
with a trash bag and somehow they figured it out that that's how they did it.
And they were able to,
the impression of the woman's face in the bag.
It was one of the creepiest things ever.
And uh,
but I gotta tell you something,
you know,
I know you just half joking around,
but most of that shit's just circumstantial evidence.
And if you don't have the weapon,
all you have is all that guys to say what I like to go hiking in that area.
Yes,
I hiked in that area.
my fibers worthy.
You know,
it's still all circumstantial at that point.
If you have no priors or anything like that,
that's a whole bunch of circumstantial evidence.
And I don't,
you know,
if you get a good lawyer,
you're going to get off,
you're going to get off.
Um,
and I think that's it for the Monday morning podcast this week.
Look at up to 54 minutes,
it happened again.
And I didn't,
you know,
why?
Cause the Goddamn fire trucks and I didn't even get a chance to get to the
underrated overrated yet.
Uh,
but you know,
these things are really building up,
so I got to blow through these,
uh,
okay.
Overrated.
Driving fast.
Not many things make me angrier on the road than when I'm driving 75 miles per
hour,
per hour.
And I'm getting tailgated really is 75 not fucking fast enough.
Few people,
you know,
something.
I,
you know,
that really annoys the shit out of me too.
Sometimes I'll bump it up to 80 and people are still riding my ass.
What the fuck?
I can understand it and appreciate the need to get somewhere quickly,
but does that,
that doesn't mean that wherever you need to go is more important than my need to
arrive at my destination at one fucking piece.
Well,
that is true,
but you know something,
I got to argue for the other guy here that if somebody is riding your ass,
you really should get out of the way,
you know.
Um,
but I know that said whole guy thing,
then he feel like a bitch,
you know.
So what are you got to do?
You've got to stomp on the breaks and be a fucking asshole.
Um,
Bob,
really,
I got to admit though,
if you are doing 75 80 in the left lane,
somebody still riding your ass.
Uh,
I dunno.
When you get a little older and more relaxed,
you don't give a fuck.
You Do,
you do go over to the right like I do now and I'll say one out of 40 times you
do that,
you actually get to see the guy get a speeding ticket a little further down the
road.
But the other 39 times,
the other 39 times you feel like a bitch.
I gotta admit underrated,
quiet time.
I remember when we used to have quiet time in grade school.
I wish that was still around.
I work at a TV station and I liked the guys I work with,
but sometimes I just need everyone to shut the fuck up.
Do we have to be running our miles every goddamn second for the next eight
hours?
Just sit there and do your work for a bit.
We'll talk later.
Jesus.
You know what dude?
I totally fucking relate to.
Exactly.
Some people just don't like fucking silence.
You know,
they find it awkward and they got to keep running the mouse kind of like me for
the last fucking hour.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
Under rated TV show the deadliest warrior on Spike TV.
Just look this shit up.
It pits two different warriors together from different time eras and they see
who would win.
Dude,
that really sounds like some nerdy fucking shit.
Isn't that like,
what do you think would win an alligator or a shark?
I don't know who they would when Shabaka or spark.
I don't get into that shit,
but you know what?
God bless you sir.
There's people out there went to it.
So I guess,
you know,
go check it out.
Uh,
real quick.
overrated women's intuition.
I've always heard educated,
intelligent women say that women's intuition is always correct.
Sorry you're wrong.
If that were true,
why do women repeatedly date abusive twisted guys?
Wouldn't their intuition tell them that the guy,
what the guy is like yet another reason of women patting themselves on the back
for no reason.
All right,
sir.
You know what?
Fuck that chick.
Okay.
Whoever dumped you just fuck her man.
You know there's going to be another good girl coming around.
Don't give into the bitterness.
Don't give into the paternal [inaudible]
or maybe that's just from dating for a while because there's a lot of,
there's a major part in me to really like that email yet.
Another example of women patting themselves on the back for no reason.
Jesus Christ.
If that sentence doesn't describe the Oprah Winfrey show,
I don't know what does.
Um,
great.
Great one.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
in women,
if you're sitting there getting mad,
you can,
you can always fucking trash guys cause I'll read them.
I'll definitely read them and I know we deserve it.
All right,
number two,
Disney movies.
Okay,
I'm 35 years old now,
but uh,
even as a kid,
I thought those a sugary shit movies suck bloody balls.
All right dude.
If I can wait and let me know how you feel.
Overrated.
Interlocking lives.
Movies like crash and fast food nation.
Get it.
We're all connected.
This shit is getting old.
That movie crash was so fucking overrated.
So fucking,
and that's one of those movies just cause it was about race.
People thought that it was saying something.
A question number four,
the movie stir crazy.
I love Richard Pryor.
He was one of the best ever.
But this movie is average.
His talent is pretty much wasted on this film.
Yeah,
I would have to say that.
Is that the one where they walk into the,
into the jail,
you know that's right.
Ah,
we bad.
We bet.
That's like the funniest part of the movie and I don't know.
I have would have to agree with you.
That's it though guys.
I'm actually coming up on a fucking hour here.
59 minutes,
25 seconds.
Listen,
that's the podcast.
You guys all have a great memorial day and I really should have made this one
short so you could actually enjoy your memorial day,
but you know what?
You got the whole week to listen to it.
And if you listen to this on Tuesday,
that means you're back at that fucking job you hate,
and I just killed an hour for you.
So God bless.
All right,
have a great week.